it's beautiful it's beautiful and uh
uh so i think you know there's a lot of
folks uh
here in iowa and my my friends from
ireland would always say
the american irish think they're more
irish than the irish
but the truth of the matter is that uh
we have a great affection for the
country and a great affection for the
tradition
and we have a ireland united states of a
robust agenda
that we've got to deal with on a
substantive side of this issue of these
issues uh
tishook and uh from combating covet
to strengthening global health security
to uh
also discussion our economic cooperation
and
ireland's leadership now and the u.n
security council which we're working
together
our un ambassador is is online with us
here
and i just welcome the leadership in
your partnership
and you know my view and the view of my
predecessor
my of the obama biden administration on
the good friday agreements we uh
we strongly support them think it's
critically important to
be maintained and the political economic
stability of northern ireland
is very much in the interest of of all
our peoples the people of people ties
and uh
i think the idea that we we talked about
about
uh renewing our partnership in the all
ireland consortium
uh cancer consortium the u.s
ireland and northern ireland it's a
partnership that
i think we can learn a lot from one
another it's one of the things that
as president tashika i am going to focus
heavily on for our national institute of
health
on dealing with uh with cancer we've all
been victims of it in terms of our
families we all
know what it's like and we're going to
make major investments in nih in
cancer research and development and i'm
looking forward to working together
as a matter of fact my relatives in
in mayo just dedicated a uh
my uh lorita one of my cousins
headed up the uh the hospice effort for
cancer not just cancer but hospice in
in ireland and they just dedicated a new
significant facility to uh my son beau
biden
who uh who died of of of cancer
and so everything between ireland and
the united st our
our joys our sorrows our passion our
drive
and our unrelenting optimism and hope
one of the few uh quotes that i've been
given credit for in my career was
i said i mean it maybe it's just my
family
i said we are the only people who are
nostalgic
for the future and i think we are
uh it's a it's a great up a great
opportunity for you and i to get to talk
a little bit so
looking forward to our conversation and
uh i'm
looking forward to getting deeper into
discussion about some of the things that
are of
great mutual interest to both of us but
as we used to say in the united states
senator tishik i yield the floor to you
thank you very much indeed and mr
president first of all
began on behalf of their people for you
express my condolences
to the people of america um and indeed
uh the people of advancing the families
of those who were killed
in uh very shocking
shootings um yesterday on the
particularly solidarity the asian
american community
we stand together against such mindless
acts of violence an enormous president
at saint patrick's day is very special
to you and
as a proud son of ireland equally i have
to tell you the
people of ireland are so proud of your
election
as president of the united states of
america
and i can think of no better day for me
and have the great pleasure
to extend to you their warmest decisions
thank you and of the nephilim court
happy and happy statement as you said it
feels strange to have to celebrate the
part
and as you know well irish people love
to come together
to celebrate our heritage and culture
with song and with dance
with parades with portraits
and with pride and this year because of
the pandemic
just simply isn't possible and here in
ireland people
are made for marking the occasion in
their homes
but they would be thinking especially of
their loved ones around the world
and sending them best thoughts and
wishes
they will do so in the hope that next
year
would be better as i believe it will
with each person vaccinated we move
closer to the day
when people can meet each other hug each
other
and celebrate again and i greatly look
forward
to you being able to visit ireland as
you have done so many times and as you
said
so memorably and before i also hope
it would not be long before i can visit
the united states again
for now the order of shamrock in front
of you
is a symbol of the undying friendship
between our two countries
is symbol of the good times we have
shared and the challenges we've endured
always at each other's side
the green shoots point to the brighter
future
that i know lies ahead building that
better future
will of course be part of what we
discussed today
the policies of our of our true
governments are very closely aligned
on the big challenges the world faces
and i look forward to exploring
how we can defeat the covet 19 virus
working together
urgently to increase a supply of vaccine
for our own people
and for people around the world we
should share notes on
our plans for recovery gaining back
the ground loss to the pandemic both the
united states and europe
have put funds of unprecedented scale in
place to support this fighting work
to build a sustainable and inclusive
future
supporting the digital and green agendas
promoting open and
fair rules-based trade delivering
greater equality and opportunity
mr president the world has rightly taken
great heart
from the steps you have already taken to
bring the us back to center stage
and global health and climate
and on human rights we want to work with
you
to promote our shared values and
interests in the world
including at the united nations security
council on which we are
as you said currently serving we want to
work with you on time and action
which becomes ever more urgent as we
approach cop 26
later and this year today
i especially want to thank you for your
unwavering support
for the good friday agreement it has met
a lot
and it has mattered including as we
negotiated
with a new trading relationship now in
between the european union
and the united kingdom and a protocol
that protects peace and avoids a hard
border around this island
i want to move forward with a positive
relationship with the united kingdom
that means standing by what has been
agreed
and working together to make it
successful
and that in turn then can help maintain
peace and
promote greater reconciliation on our
shared island
that i know you support there are so
many areas where the
irish and american people are already
working together
and we will celebrate some of them here
today
consortium through which our
practitioners and researchers would
prove their efforts
to defeat cancer that most pernicious
disease
i know it's very close to heart in terms
of dealing with that
a new initiative to share our portrait
and bring it to newer
and younger audiences that we will
announce today
mr president like you i am fundamentally
an optimist
we have all endured the most difficult
year
but alongside the suffering of the last
we have seen immense compassion
care and courage and especially from our
health workers
our educators and our volunteers
we have seen the world's best scientists
come together to deliver treatments
vaccines and hope and extraordinary pace
and i say let the same spirit of
cooperation now speed and guide our
recovery
in the year ahead thank you mr president
i look forward
to our discussion i look forward to it
as well we're going to let the people
come
[Applause]
out
thank you guys let's go thank you guys
thank you
you